So you really have to see this to believe
it.
A longtime viewer, Ned, sent me this clip.
And it is unbelievable.
Rudy Giuliani went on Fox Business yesterday
to again tell his wild conspiracies about
how Hunter Biden flew from California 3000
miles to the East Coast to drop off three
laptops at a repair shop run by a legally
blind guy and got off the plane drunk and
drove to the repair shop and then never picked
up the laptop.
So the repair guy looked at his private e-mails
and then sent them to the FBI.
That completely ridiculous story.
Rudy was on Fox Business to talk about.
And it's all so ridiculous that even the Fox
interviewer who goes by the name Kennedy actually
had to push back a little bit because what
Rudy was saying is so absurd.
And when she brings up Rudy Giuliani acting
sort of like Christopher Steele of the Steele
dossier, Rudy loses it starts demanding an
apology.
You have to see this.
We're going to jump in several minutes in.
Rudy's been ranting for about three, four
minutes completely incoherently.
And Kennedy starts to sort of question, are
these laptops even really hunters?
Is this stuff really hunters?
And it starts to get a little bit ugly.
Take a look.
Dapper.
Biden allegedly dropped the laptop off in
April 2019.
I, I believe that completely.
But you only came in possession of this 10
days ago.
So they've just been floating around for a
year and a half.
So how do we know that these laptops, if you
have cracked the encryption.
How do we know that other people haven't and
placed some of this stuff on here, especially
the most salacious stuff?
And when will you show the evidence to prove
that these are unadulterated devices?
I gave it I gave it all to The New York Post.
And they've done their own separate verification
of it with independent experts.
And they came to the conclusion that it is
hard drive.
There are internal pieces of information here
that only he could have that I know from my
investigation.
OK, so Kennedy starting to ask reasonable
questions and then keeps getting more and
more on Rudy's nerves.
And Kennedy then says, you know, we're going
to have to look into this ourselves because
it's sort of sounding a little bit weird,
Rudy.
And then Kennedy says you're sort of playing
the role of like a Christopher Steele.
Rudy flips and demands an apology.
Take a look at this.
You see 50 pictures.
All right.
Come on here.
Here's here's what we'll do.
We will have the people in our news departments
verify all of this because it sounds like
there may be something here that is fishy,
that is causing Americans.
It's giving them pause and other stuff that
might have been completely adulterated over
the 18 months.
And some can say that you were acting like
Christopher Hill, that that you were abstracting
information.
And because you gotta be kidding me.
I was acting I was acting like Christopher
Steele.
That's what it sounds like when you apologize.
You better apologize for that.
I mean, I've been I've been a United States
attorney, associate attorney general, mayor
of New York City and a member of the board
for 50 years.
I've never been accused of anything.
And you're accusing me of being Christopher
Steele.
I'm accusing you of agents who would do that.
Nothing you to Christopher Steele.
And that simply link back and forth between
the university culture of justice and the
unit you are saying is an outrageous defamation.
So that escalated very quickly.
It goes from Rudy having essentially seven
minutes to rant incoherently to Rudy, demanding
an apology from the interviewer and accusing
her of defamation.
You have to love it.
Let's keep going.
And Rudy just keeps demanding apologies of
me, of my reputation.
Every single thing is here.
And I want you to look at it.
I let you apologize for making it.
Well, you can you can you can come to my office
and you can look at it.
And tomorrow night you can apologize to me.
I'm Christopher Steele.
I told you, there are underage girls there.
There are.
I told you there are documents that show that
he's getting 10 percent.
There are there are documents that show that
he's getting half of what Hunter gets.
There are when they are there.
I want you to apologize to me.
Because you just defame me.
Absolutely.
That's outrageous because you have no basis
for that.
I came on your show in good faith to give
you evidence that is being withheld from the
American people.
And I get defamed.
Isn't that great?
Rudy wants to be able to peddle these obvious
lies and these ridiculous, disjointed conspiracy
theories with no resistance.
Any resistance, even mild and meek, is not
going to be allowed.
And Kennedy is doing her best not to allow
Rudy to rant endlessly with no with no questions
being asked.
Then Rudy decides we've got to end this interview.
That's outrageous.
All right.
Are you still working on behalf?
I think our interview I think our interview
is now over.
I haven't even gotten I don't talk to people
who accuse more or the part about nineteen
ninety four in the Video Music Awards.
That was the last time you and I were on camera.
And it's taken this long and these.
Yeah.
And it won't be the last time on camera because
I don't let people call me Christopher Steele.
I'm sorry.
Christopher Hill is a criminal.
You're asserting that I'm a criminal.
I know that Eastern Europe is a cesspool and
American.
I didn't get from Eastern Europe.
I didn't get them from Eastern Europe.
You are now repeating lying propaganda from
the Democratic National Committee and the
crooked Biden family.
I had nothing to do with Eastern Europe.
I got this from the the repairman who corroborated.
Yeah.
Come on, Kennedy.
That's not fair.
He didn't get the stuff from Eastern Europe.
He got it from a legally blind guy who didn't
actually say he identified Hunter Biden as
the guy dropping off the laptops, but he saw
a Beau Biden sticker on the laptops and determined
that clearly was Hunter Biden who dropped
these laptops off to me 3000 miles away from
where he lives.
You're not being fair to Rudy.
By allowing him to tell that story.
What a world.
What a world we live in.
And then here, just the last few moments,
Rudy attacking the interviewer as not being
informed.
All right.
Do you regret have this.
This is Hunter Biden's.
This is Hunter Biden's material.
It has proven 100 times over.
And I have a voice recording of him in which
he talks about being in business with the
Chinese spymaster.
Maybe you should play the recording and see
if I don't have it.
It's been all over the Internet today.
And if you were better informed, he would
have known that.
Oh, I've I've read plenty about this.
I have.
And it's it's.
Have you.
Have you heard the recording that's been out
there all day of Hunter Biden saying that
he is in business with a Chinese spymaster,
Patrick Ho, and that his big partner, the
richest man in China, may be dead and that
he and his father may be called as witnesses?
Did you hear that one?
No.
We've not been able to verify large swaths
of the material that has allegedly come yet.
That's because you don't want to verify it.
I would love to hear your sister find your
sister, your sister, your sister and entity.
The New York Post has verified it took five
days to do it.
Yeah, I had I have the opinion never from
the police.
You think that printing's you think they're
printing false material.
You think Rupert Murdoch would let them print
false material?
Heavens.
Now, just because I gave it to them and there
is the sort of catch to this entire thing.
It's not about let them print knowingly false
material.
It's about printing unverified speculative
And the answer is, of course, that's what
The New York Post does.
And then Fox News opinion, people use it to
say, hey, this was reported by The New York
Post giving them sort of a veneer of plausible
deniability.
It's just hilarious.
And really, this is no big praise of Kennedy.
This is just again.
It's like the people who are criticizing Lesley
Stahl for being too tough on Trump in any
other country with a free press.
I mean, OK.
North Korea, you're not going to get it.
But in other countries with a free press.
Presidents are much more regularly exposed
to tough questioning and any mild questioning
Rudy just doesn't want.
And Rudy, just just just think, as we have
six days now left until this election.
Rudy is on that list along with Jared Kushner.
And Ivonka, Kaili Magnani, Don Junior.
That is the list of people who hopefully after
Tuesday, we never have to hear from again.
That is as much as I'm incentivized to remove
Trump because we need somebody to start writing
the ship.
I am also very incentivized by getting all
of these clowns off until they get deals to
be contributors to Fox News, of course, at
least temporarily off of the airwaves as people
involved in government.
Really, really insane stuff.
But at least to the extent that Kennedy caused
Rudy to implode.
Nicely done.
But don't go too far praising her because
she is still, you know, who she is